Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so finally my agent
of shield episode two video so much awesome
stuff happening this week and again fits is
like the repeat top performer in the episode
he is killing it in his first couple of episodes
Marvel also just confirmed Ant Man two it's gonna be
Ant-man and the WASP and have a couple untitled films
they just put on the board so I'm gonna talk
about that after shortstops so be sure to
stick around to the end of the video but getting
the show stuff just careful response in the
episode if you haven't seen it yet 30 with
top five WTF moments number five we find out
what may has been doing this whole time she's
been hanging out with her father who looks
like is estranged from her mother who is also
pretty hilarious if you look at this from
a Joseph Campbell perspective heroes journey
may is just like refusing the call obviously
now we can start to find out what her arc
is gonna be the season we don't quite know
that you haven't spell that out is kind of
like a big sister figure to Skye Michelle
Susan superhot on the edge of all these in
humans I would say you like in terms of people
inside shield and insight tinkles and that
like in humans and people that don't like
them I was a she's closer to Mac, Mac doesn't
hate them either but he sounds like he really
doesn't want have anything to do with them
if he doesn't have to I'd be amazed if you
didn't recognize the actor that played May's
father he shows up so much of his like a comedy
ninja he shows up for little while out of
nowhere is hilarious and then just vanishes
into the night is a lot of voiceover work
to probably the last biggest thing that you
recognize him from is from kung fu panda he
played pose father the duck father I just
love the idea that may Special Agent comes
from a family of special agents even though
you wouldn't know just from looking at her
father but releasing pattern is formed here
we know it may does now when she just completely
fried as a human being she goes back and hangs
out with her parents is bad asses the Calvary
is she is still human is in that what most
people would do like when their life just
completely crumbles around them like they
don't know what to do like okay I'm cynical
stay with my parents for a few days I can
talk about May all day including the fact
that she looks younger than the twentysomethings
on the show despite the fact that may not
is pushing 50 like that's how amazing she
looks but on the number for another missing
character comes back toward his back and he
needs a ton of cash enter new character from
the weavers you definitely heard right this
is Baron von Strucker son remember he was
killed during avengers interval try he sounds
really American even though his father's Europeans
I'm guessing he was raised abroad the way
he explained that he knew his father was a
part of Hydra but he wasn't allowed to participate
in any Hydra shenanigans Rita's love how Ward
plays on his daddy issues to bring him to
the dark side your father see to the table
now belongs to you reach out and take it but
that's what he told him to kill that other
hydration he like to go ahead take it it's
yours do it to the thing is a great story
arc I really hope that it pans out I think
we'll find out by the midseason finale using
that's when the course correctly before the
back half like if things don't pan out they
tried leave room to adjust the stories with
like if it is actors if the storyline goes
nowhere they can kill them off if they want
with his actor is actually from Joss Whedons
much ado about nothing he was one of the younger
actors and that of course we burst very big
very famous for raising new talent out of
obscurity a civilian probably the best example
that so Junior von struck are now firmly embedded
with shield via the psychiatrist at his school
the Blair characters interesting I do like
the idea of shows psychoanalyzing themselves
as long as it doesn't get too literal but
just think of him is like a narrative device
for the show to comment on itself like as
he psychoanalyze the characters he's actually
psychoanalyzing the direction the shows going
the biggest part of that are the secret warriors
and yes you he totally mentioning secret orders
but they said that they were doing sycamores
a long time was like that family guy joke
where you peters pointing the sKreen it's
like all they said the name of the movie and
the movie they did the thing I got hijacked
my number three WTF moment for that product
placement though that Jaguar add they did
in the middle the episode that was total product
placement exam he does my picked up on that
to if you re-watch and listen toward speech
he's basically describing a really awesome
car like they want you to buy the Jaguar it's
an F type is a typical car we need a new image
the funny thing is is that during the Super
Bowl they did a big Jaguar ad with a bunch
of British actors Tom Hiddleston was one of
them it was like a Jaguar villains that it
was a joke about how really stereotypical
big British villains love jaguars because
they are obsessed with power is totally sinister
so of course it's appropriate that they would
use Hydra to create product integration for
the show I think it's hilarious but on the
number two guest star as guardian who is in
prison voluntarily it looks like I love when
they broke them out he was just like okay
let's do it he literally open the bars as
if it was just a door they kind of explain
this is for movies like the difference in
the physiology between as guardians and humans
as guardians typically live about 5000 years
they're not like celestial beings or anything
like that but is highly evolved humanoids
that live on a different plane there physiology
is also a lot more resilient so they heal
wounds a lot faster that's why Loki is able
to eat a blast from the destroyer gun did
not die and they captured him during season
two but I like his performance this season
better it just is a little more tongue-in-cheek
this is a little more comedy he really likes
living on earth so he's going to just trying
to hide out not make too much noise that's
why he doesn't try to kill Coulson the first
chance he gets just because he just wants
to be left alone does have is fun most of
the scientific concepts they mentioned during
his scenes were references to Thor movies
like the Einstein Rosen bridge that's the
rainbow bridge thingy which number one WTF
moment they get Simmons back after realizing
that the monolith is a doorway to another
planet on the other side of the universe were
all asking the exact same question here what
is the planet that Simmons was sent to is
it Morag is in another Kree outpost is it
something were to see during guardians of
the Galaxy will say right now is I definitely
do not think that it is Atalanta I think that
it is just another Kree outpost no I do not
think that will see this planet specifically
mentioned during guardians of the Galaxy to
but I do think that they will find out where
it is on the show after they came back the
monolith exploded best is to let you know
that the nuts can be jumping back and forth
between planets all the time why then with
the writers send Simmons a way to another
planet in the hiatus and then bring her back
so fast like what you what's the point of
the ringer back so fast on the surface what
I think is going on is that they just want
to incorporate the timeless nature of the
in humans there and ancient Kree experiment
that they abandoned eons ago but they left
their equipment lying around it still works
so people continue to use it so the in humans
continue to evolve on their own sheltered
from humanity so I think lassies and dragging
in humans colony is just the beginning I think
that will learn a lot more about in human
society not the royal family mind you I don't
and on the pussy any royal family members
to the in humans movie which is years and
years away I don't think we can see Atalanta
but I do think that will hear about it we
got a taste of Kree outpost I think the dislikes
slowly raising that bar eventually will probably
learn that last comes from another group of
in humans so maybe midseason finale may be
second half of the season will learn about
them he was really present in this episode
but I think it is laying the groundwork to
explain where he comes from and why he's doing
what he's doing like why you are killing always
new in humans but I'm so happy that Simmons
and Fitz are together again I feel like they
work best when they're together if you never
lassies and it was all about Fitz trying to
survive his trauma now it's all about Simmons
trying to survive her trauma so where Simmons
was trying to help Fitz lassies and now can
be the other way around some you asked me
if I think that Simmons is an in human actually
do think that she has in human DNA and her
but I don't know that the show will ever take
her through tears and he says the crazy thing
about the as guardian is is that he didn't
seem to have any kind of idea what activated
the monolith I think that it's activated by
people with in human DNA let me know in the
comments that planet the Simmons went to do
you think that that is where Lasch is from
and do you think that were gonna see another
monolith somewhere on earth the season with
the episode was great I still keep expecting
them to raise their game I think it could
get even better it's the same with arrow the
flash to vastly better than they were in previous
seasons just Academy things into Marvel movie
territory but I have a that a marble movie
video in a little while the marble just confirmed
that Ant Man to is gonna be Ant Man the wasp
that's gonna be the title it's gonna drop
July 6, 2018 of that is like a long ways off
but that is confirming that it's gonna be
a think Evangeline Lilly will be in full battle
attire just expect them to tweak the costume
from the end of Ant Man like if you saw the
post rinsing with the whop suit just expect
them to tweak a little bit they also announced
a couple of untitled movies even further out
than that and here's what I think is going
on there probably just clearing space for
Capt. Marvel Sequel in case that successful
and a hold movie if they get the distribution
rights back from universal that the reason
that you haven't seen a so hopeful yet is
not because marble doesn't want to do it they
definitely want to do another whole film especially
because Margaret was so awesome universal
still holds the distribution rights for whole
films in that kind like an indefinite think
there's no end date on that Disney is like
one of the largest film distribution companies
in the world they don't need anyone else to
release their films so they don't want to
give away a giant chunk of the profits to
other companies so they're not in a release
another whole film until they get the distribution
rights back when you're thinking about these
untitled movies just think about sequels to
the brand-new movies that are coming out like
you have Dr. strange they're probably clearing
path for Dr. strange Sequel should it happen
and I definitely think it will here's a question
if you guys though they have Dr. strange and
Capt. Marvel in and I like the wasp and Ant
Man coming back who else do you guys want
to see them introduce in the marvel universe
I know we all of the she hoped we want to
see spider woman but I don't the dignity she
hold until they do another solo whole film
and I don't think that the gonna do spider
woman until the new Spider Man franchise launches
is proven successful which I definitely think
it will be we can talk more about future mobile
phones in the video so be sure to subscribe
to get everything I haven't arrow flask unit
that will be posting next couple trail videos
I might shovel those rounds the little bit
we finally got a Jessica Jones teaser with
some purple man in his legs you know what
I might do that next is because I'm doing
this moral video right now like as if lots
of the post you can click here for last night's
episode of arrow to get something that video
yet and you can click here for all my Jessica
Jones trailer videos thank you so much watching,
let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight!